Hello Freak bitches.
So if you start,
if you take a guitar string and
you split it into four equal parts,
you put your finger over a one quarter
of the string and then you start just hug
plucking the string and hovering above
the string so you don't actually push it
to the fret board.
Those notes occur naturally
as the harmonics and the
expansion of the vibrating
string.
So that those notes were not
really chosen by Roy Orbison.
Whoever wrote the song,
they were really chosen
by like a four gay series.
Um,
and it feels like it's a riff,
but I discovered this when
I was in Indonesia as I
would start playing that and
people would react.
I thought like,
why that song?
What about more complex creative and
sort of improvisational song like Voodoo
child from Hendrix?
So I don't know about Voodoo child and
I'm following along,
you know,
I mean,
well take taking out and it changes up.
So if you look at the first
couple of cords of red house,
there's like some seventh
or diminished chord.
Like he's Pegi Nana,
and then he moves it down a half step,
which has to do with this
tritone substitution and
the symmetry inside of the
seventh chord.
So if I recall correctly,
you have a chord like c e g B flat would
be a c seven chord and the e and the B
flat would form this
thing called a tri tone.
And now if you went in the blues,
you,
there are three elements
of the chord progression,
the dominant subdominant and the tonic.
If you go down a half step,
you effectively invert the
third and the flat seventh.
Uh,
so if you go one half step below that,
it's the flat seventh and the third
I think of the subdominant court.
So Hendricks is actually playing
with math in something as basic as,
do you think he's aware of it or do
you think he's doing it sort of just
instinctual?
Well,
first of all,
when you're visited by
an alien intelligence,
we went through cuddle fish and we,
now we've gotten the Jimi Hendrix.
So yeah,
that's like,
these are the,
these are the best
alien sightings we have.
It's very hard to speculate,
but I,
I,
I just look at everything I've been able
to understand about what he did and you
know,
you're dealing with the
supermind as well as an intuitive
mastery of the instrument.
Complete understanding of the chords
and progressions and just the ability to
improvise and to make it sound different.
Adding the Wah Wah pedal and all that
distortion and all this shit that he used
to do.
And the fact that he
imparts more into one note,
like I wouldn't even know how to notate.
I mean what does even the
instrument and play the guitar,
he played the guitar amplification,
you know,
signal processing system as a whole.
So,
you know,
there are these people who are just
in some multidimensional space.
Another one of my favorites is,
uh,
a guy named Roy Buchanan who some have
these guys who understand the harmonics
of gravitate to telecasters and um,
you know,
pull up song called Roy's blues and
watch him just go into the multiverse and
start playing with things that you
can't even imagine are possible.
So I do think that there is a very close
relationship between algorithms and
emotion.
Wait,
but wait,
Harvey,
he was the guy that would
give girls the shoulder rubs.
He would tell them to massage him.
Oh,
he massaged them.
They would massage him.
He would do according to these girls.
I don't know if it's true,
but he'd be the guy that would be,
I'll be right back.
And he comes back in a bathrobe.
He's a bathrobe guy.
Here's the thing.
I don't mean to make light of anybody's
sexual assault or whatever it was or
harassment,
but other working on the roof.
Again,
wonderful.
But,
but what I,
but here's the thing.
How many women said yes,
that will be a fuck load.
Like that was his move.
What we're seeing is his missed pitches,
right?
He hit by a lot of fucking
triples and home runs,
knocked a lot of balls out of the park,
but occasionally he was
wiffen occasionally.
He was like,
I got this one in the bag boys.
And she's like,
fuck off you pig.
And he's like,
oh,
come on.
Just come back to my room.
No,
no,
no.
It's like shit down.
What happened Harvey?
Oh,
just wasn't connecting.
I wasn't connecting.
But listen,
I got all this,
those as a girl wants to be in the next
fucking this movie and Avatar 16 and
she's willing to do the
thing to get the part.
And that's kind of like that guys,
they can get the part and get
your money and get on with it.
How many girls read the story when it
broke and could still taste the asparagus,
caviar flavored come just the
cocaine and VOD color in his loads.
I bet he has like a Flemmi
like Moan when he comes.
He's a Kinda guy
spittle and the corners of his,
now let's try to hit on you.
He's got a little bit bubble are his lip.
He's nasty.
That's a gluttonous man control.
It's not attractive.
It's definitely not.
My favorite too is that
he would jerk off into,
did you hear this?
But he plants
his green.
He wants to exist off of his loads.
That's such a desperate thing.
Like on,
can we get it?
Can I have it?
No.
Okay,
stay here then let me,
you know,
like it's so maybe it was hoping
they would just dive in the grade
of a soldier,
but I also like,
I was thinking too,
I've,
I've seen so many dudes jerking
off in public like homeless guys.
Yeah.
I never got anything for it.
Is it,
you know,
good point.
Yeah.
It's so much better to do it in a class.
Oh,
it holds you accountable.
Yeah.
It holds you accountable and it's flooded.
There's no bullshit.
[inaudible] this is going to be unit
fucking to hold this pose for 30 seconds
period.
This is 30 seconds,
you know,
and you do it as much as you can
and your fucking feet are shaking.
And my favorite one,
my favorite one is this one.
Oh yeah.
You go down here and you have to sit here.
Yeah.
I love that fucking post.
That's what I love that one
because I was a catcher,
so it's like,
it goes right back to my strength
because I don't want to work.
I love that fucking post.
I go deep when,
when she goes out I go deep
and that and the plain one.
Where are you?
Come on.
Good one.
Tom and I,
Tom and I had been talking
about doing a calendar,
a Yoga [inaudible] Yoga
calendar of 12 months.
Me and Tom and different poses together,
all this shit up thing.
You would sell the shit out of that thing.
That's a great idea.
Jamie.
You would take different photography.
A couple of couples
poses down by the beach.
Yeah,
that's not what we're talking about Jamie.
We want to do a Bikram hot,
sweaty,
uh,
maybe both of us in speedos.
Oh yeah.
And,
and,
and hold our favorite poses.
Where you to get those jeans shorts.
I'd wear those in a heartbeat.
The Shyness Eg.
The second we went in,
the first cost we went in,
Tom Goes,
uh,
he sees a guy in the speed own.
He goes,
how are you not wearing a speedo?
He's like,
this is your whole thing.
And I was like,
I don't know.
My favorite Tommy Bond story in Yoga
or instructor starts telling a story,
you know,
like in between poses.
He's telling a story and like the first
30 minutes of class about his son and
him in New York and his son walking and
his son being out of breath and whatnot,
and then continues on with the poses.
Last 30 minutes of class,
we are fucking panting.
We're on our stomachs.
Face to the left,
hands down by your side.
And I hear t in a silent
class or your Tom go,
hey man.
Hey,
what happened?
And he's just talking loud as shit.
Scared the fuck out of me because what
happened with you and your son in New
York?
The guy goes,
excuse me guys.
Tommy was,
you never put your story,
man.
I've been waiting for
this end of the story.
And you just kept dragging on and like,
and he keeps talking and I
am in shaking Mexico going,
shut the fuck up Tom.
Fucking yoga.
It does.
The guy finished and then the guy goes,
uh,
that was it.
And Tom Goes,
oh,
okay.
Oh
yeah.